es ist dieser baum der in der nacht zu
einem todes baum wurde dort ist ein 18
jähriger mit seinem auto dagegen gras
drei insassen waren dabei
ja und am ende ist es der 18 jährige
fahrer der überlebt und die drei
mitfahrer wahrscheinlich seine freunde
sind tot
drei junge männer sterben bei einem
schweren unfall nahe hofheim am taunus
in der nacht zu samstag waren die
insgesamt vier männer im alter von 17
bis 18 jahren mit ihrem wagen auf der
landstraße unterwegs
aus bislang unbekannter ursache verlor
der 18-jährige fahrer in einer kurve die
kontrolle über das fahrzeug und prallte
mit der beifahrerseite voraus gegen zwei
bäume
die beiden insassen auf der rückbank
waren sofort tot der fahrer wurde auf
seinem sitz eingeklemmt der beifahrer
unter dem fahrzeug aufgefunden
er verstarb später im krankenhaus nur
der 18 jährige fahrer überlebt den
unfall schwer verletzt die polizei hat
die ermittlungen zur ursache des unfalls
aufgenommen
jessica fehler ist unsere frau vor
jessica du stehst an dem todes baum kann
man da irgendwelche spuren erkennen was
kannst du uns neues sagen
also ich muss sagen die letzten stunden
hierzu stehen zu beobachten was alles
geschehen ist war wirklich fast
unerträglich hier liegen überall noch
fetzen von den auto kommen auto
autoteile hinter mir sieht man den baum
die komplette rede ist da abgegangen man
sieht richtig richtig tiefe furchen wo
man nur erahnt haben wie heftig diese
aus
sein musste das komplette metall der
richtige kratzer reingebissen hat es
haben mich im laufe des tages immer
wieder angehörige versammelt die haben
dann in den trümmern
persönliche gegenstände gefunden die
sonnenbrille gehört haben werden sie
unterwegs waren und auch das foto was
hinter mir ist wurde aufgehängt mit vier
festen schrauben an den baum geschraubt
hier sind die angehörigen weinen
zusammengebrochen
ein motorrad sterne als es war wirklich
sehr sehr sehr dramatiker das hört sich
wirklich ganz schrecklich an auch für
dich vor ort was sagt denn die polizei
weiß man irgendwie wie dieser unverletzt
zustande gekommen ist
also zudem tat vorgang zum tathergang
also wieder unter passiert ist hat die
polizei sich jetzt noch ziemlich bedeckt
gehalten sagen die ermittlungen laufen
und sie konnten jetzt noch nichts neues
sagen okay und ist sind schon mehr
bekannt über den 18-jährigen fahrer über
dessen zustand er hat ja quasi seine
freunde auf dem gewissen muss man ja
fast sagen schrecklich also ich würde
auf keinen fall so sagen dass er seine
freundin irgendeiner weise auf dem
gewissen hat
es war sebastian reich der junge mit
vornamen hat dann achtzehnten geburtstag
gefeiert
heute sind es scheint erst zwei tage
lang und dann ist dieser schreckliche
unfall passiert es ist vielmehr ein
tragischer unfall als dass irgendjemand
mal auf dem gewissen hätten und ich
glaube niemand von uns möchte in diesem
moment in meiner haut stecken da hast du
vollkommen recht vielen dank jessica für
den moment und alles gute dir noch danke
dir